IT expert to be a shuttle joins us to be
us you're also a good hacker aren't you
absolutely yes what makes you a good
hacker not a bad hacker oh the good
hackers try to find problems in software
and report it to the companies that have
these problems rather than making them
public or stealing data and how'd you
become a hacker well actually to be a
gamma wrecker that's nothing you can
learn it's something you have in your in
your mind in your attitude because
hackers try to break into systems and
they look at these systems quite
different than regular users do so it's
something you have to think differently
than normal people there's obviously
money to be made out of this if i may
ask how much money have you made out of
this sort of career you mean from from
hacking hacking well well not so much
because i never worked with these bug
bounty programs so that was not my
attitude in getting money out of that it
was like for getting information
learning things and preventing problems
to be made again and again and stop
these these books so there's big bucks
to be made out of it also a proper
career yes absolutely because what I'm
currently doing is I'm starting
awareness program so I'm teaching
companies and users how hackers work and
how they can prevent being a victim in
the future well what do you say to them
what how do you convince them that they
actually need someone to upgrade their
systems well if you talk with users it's
nothing you can teach them because they
are working in completely different
positions and not are not IT experts so
what I can tell these people is if you
recognize something is maybe strange or
look strange go to the IT experts and
tell them because they are happy if they
know there's something going on and they
are the ones to check if it's an attack
or not but is hacking against hack is
the best way of doing it or the only way
of really effectively doing it now of
course you have to have systems
preventing hackers from accessing your
data but we know systems always have
problems they have box they have yeah
well mistakes being made from
programmers from users and stuff like
that so
every company is very very happy if you
tell them hey there's a problem in your
system rather than finding this
information in the media somewhere else
or let's say in the dark net and having
other people accessing these data for
weeks probably but but not every company
is on board immediately I mean that's
why you give these sessions exactly why
is it so much more of a trend over the
other side of the Atlantic in the United
States for example well I'm not really
sure why it's over there probably
because the biggest companies the
biggest Internet companies are located
there that might be a reason but it's
starting here in Europe as well
especially also in Germany like with
Deutsche Telekom as we have seen before
these companies know there are thousands
or ten thousands of good educated
hackers out there and it's the best way
to have them work for you playing your
rules rather than having hackers not
knowing who they are playing their rules
and attacking your systems in real time
so it's all about being in control to